leer gefegten straßen geschlossene
restaurants geschäfte und bewaffnete
polizeikontrollen an öffentlichen
plätzen
seit mittlerweile sechs tagen hat israel
als erstes land auf der welt den zweiten
lok dorn ausgerufen nachdem die korona
zahlen in den letzten wochen auf bis zu
6000 neue infektionen pro tag gestiegen
sind zog ministerpräsident netanjahu die
reißleine für vorerst drei wochen
bleiben schulen geschlossen das
öffentliche leben pausiert und die
israelis dürfen sich maximal einen
kilometer um ihr zuhause bewegen das
gesundheitssystem in israel scheint
zusammenzubrechen die schwer erkrankten
patienten brauchen rund um die uhr
betreuung und wenn das nicht mehr
sichergestellt werden kann wird die zahl
der toten weiter steigen
tausende polizisten kontrollieren
passanten sitzen die strengen regeln
durch harte maßnahmen im kampf gegen
korona nicht alle haben verständnis für
die entscheidung eines zweiten lok downs
15 milliarden euro pro woche sollen laut
opposition dem land an wirtschaftlichen
schaden entstehen israel hat nach der
ersten corona welle die maßnahmen
schnell wieder gelockert wird ihnen das
jetzt zum verhängnis
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dir hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren